Katie Couric wanted to make the case for
fluidity of gender instead she made the
case against abortion yes seriously
appearing with Ellen DeGeneres to talk
about her new documentary gender
revolution Katie Couric p.m. spouting
off about gender in the womb gender
Couric explained was quote really a
deeply biological thing an unintentional
wringing rebuke to the gender is a
social construct crowd she then added
just because you operate on a child and
tell the child you're a certain gender
that doesn't necessarily coincide with
who that person feels he or she actually
is this applies really to intersex
children not generally a biologically
male or female children but Couric
forged ahead said quote in the later
stages of development it's when the
brain is wired and sometimes a surge of
testosterone can make a female fetus
feel as if that baby is male or that
person is male and the opposite if
there's not enough testosterone put
aside the gender politics of this
argument for just a second the science
isn't really settled as to how a baby is
really male or female in the brain based
on hormone surges science actually
suggests Korek is wrong but instead
focus on Couric's argument that a fetus
can quote feel as if that baby or that
person is a particular gender a fetus is
not a clump of cells it's not a ball of
tissue it feels things as Ed Morrissey
of hot air points out quote if we're to
suddenly sensitize ourselves of the
deeply biological implications of the
fetuses own perception of gender
identity can we finally agree a fetus is
an actual human with a right to its own
life as well as its own gender identity
this is where the entire logic of
leftism on abortion breaks down the left
focuses incessantly on the victim status
of various human beings from various
racial sexual ethnic groups the left
will sing the lyrics to Born This Way
with all their heart but then they'll
attempt to argue that until you're born
you weren't this way that's ridiculous
if we're going to talk about the
ultimate victim group let's talk about
unborn children who have done nothing to
deserve their fate or developing human
beings in the womb if it takes them talk
about intersex babies to make leftist
care about babies all of a sudden that
is certainly worth the price I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay we're gonna get to everything Trump
related in a second plus it was a good
time over at Ferris State University
we'll talk a little bit about that a
little bit later but first we have to
thank our new supporters our new
advertisers over at zip recruiter com so
if you are a business person and you're
looking for the best person to fill that
slot zip recruiter is the place to go
right now with zip recruiter instead of
posting your job to all these message
boards and hoping somebody responds to
you instead what you do the zip recorder
as you post your job to 200-plus job
sites including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter with one click
saves you tons of time you find
candidates in any city or industry
nationwide you post once and you watch
those candidates roll on in the zip
recruiters easy-to-use interface you
don't have to worry about emails or
calls to your office you can screen
candidates and rate them and hire them
really quickly
it's used by Fortune 100 companies all
over the planet right now my listeners
can post jobs on zip recruiter for free
by going to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire one more time you try it for
free zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
plus if you're someone who's seeking a
job you put your name up there on kind
of a general message board over at zip
recruiter and that allows all of the
people who are looking to hire people to
find you its zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire make sure that you use the
slash daily wire because that enables
them to know that we sent you number one
and number two it means that you get to
do it for free so go check it out for
free zip recruiter comm slash daily what
a great service
alright so as I mentioned a minute ago
Katie Couric now thinks that I mean this
is good news I suppose all left is logic
in the end turns in on itself and that's
certainly true of abortion I think it's
amusing that Katie Couric now only
thinks babies are babies if they are
intersex babies or transgender babies so
apparently babies who are not any of
those things maybes you don't suffer
from those conditions those are not
babies but if you're transgender baby
then you're a baby which is just kind of
weird but in any case that wasn't the
only stupid thing to come out yesterday
Hillary Clinton is back oh yes she's
back she was wandering the woods the
children emerged from those woods
weeping and told tales of a hellhound
loose in the woods crying over her own
fate and now she's back Hillary Clinton
is here she's come
here's Hillary Clinton she's saying
things about ladies and vaginas and such
despite all the challenges we face I
remain convinced that yes the future is
female just look at the amazing energy
I'm sure the future is female okay let's
just be factual about one thing here the
future is asexual and the future is
gender fluid the future is a temporal
state again future male or female or
black are why I hate this kind of
phraseology it's so dumb but again it
all comes back to that intersectionality
politics that the left is so focused on
babies are only babies if they're
transgender babies and the future is
only the future if it's female for some
odd reason by the way if the future is
only female then you sort of do wonder
how babies are gonna get made in the
future are there any babies in the
future is like the future one generation
of females and then everyone dies or
they live forever like the like the
Amazonians in Wonder Woman land and no
one really knows but Hillary Clinton
continues along these lines because she
just won't go away
here she here she continues last month
as women organized a March that
galvanized millions of people all over
our country and across the world so
please set an example for every woman
and girl out there who's worried about
what the future holds and wonders
whether our rights opportunities and
values will endure and remember you are
the heroes and history makers the glass
ceiling breakers of the future as I've
said before I'll say again never doubt
that you are valuable and powerful and
deserving of every chance and
opportunity in the world okay I have a
daughter and she is just three now and I
also think that she is going to have a
wonderful future I also don't think
she's gonna have a lot of glass ceilings
to break her mom's a doctor
her grandmother runs a television firm
the the country is replete with rich and
powerful women America 55% of voters are
women 55% of the people in college are
women 58 percent of the people with
graduate degrees our women the idea that
women are suffering on mass in the
United States which is what Hillary
seems to you
overcome we shall you overcame okay
you're the majority of voters you're the
majority of the people in college you're
the min in 147 out of 150 of the biggest
most populous cities women who are
single and unmarried and worked the same
number of hours as men earn 8% more on
average than men do so can we cut it out
with this whole glass ceiling shattered
routine it's really irritating and when
Hillary Clinton does it it's even more
irritating because the fact of the
matter is that Hillary Clinton's
shattering of glass ceiling involved her
marrying a more powerful man and then
riding his coattails to to all sorts of
glory but not the White House but not
the White House after my favorite
headline of the day it was apparently
there's some couple that's been married
I guess for 22 years I've been together
for 22 years and they're breaking up
over Trump and the first thing that went
through my mind is I'm really feeling
bad for the Clintons that's terrible I
can't believe they broke up over Trump
okay so Hillary lost obviously because
if you watch her there it's impossible
for her not to lose because she's awful
but Donald Trump is now the president
and so this comes with its benefits and
it comes with its drawbacks do we have a
little bit of good Trump bad from shall
we do that today yes all right so Donald
Trump speaks yesterday at CENTCOM
Central Command and he is um and and he
he does something that is that is not
quite true but is also kind of smart so
in the middle of this it's sort of
unintentionally smart I think in the in
the myth is a good Trump in the middle
of his speech at CENTCOM he drops the
notion that the media have not covered
terrorism properly here's what he has to
say radical Islamic terrorists are
determined to strike our homeland as
they did on 9/11 as they did from Boston
to Orlando to San Bernardino and all
across Europe you've seen what happened
in Paris and nice all over Europe it's
happening it's gotten to a point where
it's not even being reported and in many
cases the very very dishonest press
doesn't want to report it they have
their reasons and you understand that I
do love the fact that as time goes on
Donald Trump sounds more and more like
Marlon Brando from The Godfather he's
meeting to lose his voice now and
he's kind of sitting there petting a cat
and telling you about terrorism but
aside from that what he says that about
the media not properly covering
terrorism it's sort of true and it's
sort of not true so it is not true that
the press does not cover terrorism in
fact of the 78th a realist elite
released a list of 78 attacks since 2014
that they said had not received enough
media attention and on that list were
terrorist attacks in Nice France and
terrorist attacks in Berlin and the
terror attack in Orlando I'm pretty sure
those received enough media attention
but here's what's smart about all of
this here's a smart about all of this it
has forced the media now to go back and
rehash all of the terrorist incidents
the media are so crazy and so stupid
that Trump says you didn't cover the
terrorist attacks enough and instead of
them just saying that's not true now
this is a misdirect because you actually
want to talk about X Y Z instead the
media goes into how dirty will show you
how much we covered terrorist attacks
and will cover them anew just to prove
you wrong and from sitting there
smirking at himself knowing that the
entire prompt the entire premise of that
speech the entire premise of him saying
that was designed to force the media to
spend lots of time talking about terror
attacks so suddenly Americans would
recognize what he's trying to do with
his Immigration and Refugee or her it's
amazing and now I'm not gonna credit
Donald Trump by playing for T chess
because I think very few people in
politics actually play for T chess I
think most people who play for T chests
are as I said a couple of days ago just
like the wookie and youyou sometimes let
the wookie win the Wookiee doesn't know
how to play 40 chess he just gonna rip
your arms out and beat you to death with
them I think that's more what Trump is
doing here but the media is so stupid
but they make Trump who's playing like
regular chess look like he's playing 4d
chess by comparison Sean Spicer not
Melissa McCarthy should actual Sean
Spicer was out there defending this
yesterday and it's pretty funny
several great update today on the fight
against Isis that's going on throughout
the region what our military is facing
throughout the world kind of bad Isis
but there's a lot of instances that have
occurred where I don't think they've got
the covers and again reiterating this
point is smart because number one every
time from picks a fight with the media
and then the media allow him to do that
every time the media kick back by saying
how dare he attack the media Americans
go I don't care about you you're the
media why would I possibly care if Trump
attacks you you attack each other fine
whatever it's smart of Trump so this is
it so this is good Trump and then
there's bad Trump's from speaking at
CENTCOM and Trump again reiterates that
this that NATO is somehow a boondoggle
and NATO allies have to pay more money
or we're gonna the tasks of threat is
we're going to cut them off here's Trump
talking about NATO at CENTCOM we
strongly support NATO we only ask that
all of the NATO members make their full
and proper financial contributions to
the NATO alliance which many of them
have not been doing many of them have
not been even close
and they have to do that so Trump says
that and a lot of people say okay we'll
look he's expressing his support for
NATO okay juxtapose that the way he just
talked about NATO with the way he talks
about Vladimir Putin we've killed a lot
of people also we kill lots of people
also he's much more sympathetic
apparently just from the tone of his
rhetoric to Vladimir Putin than he is to
NATO and that's a problem that's a
problem because the fact is that there's
a great piece in foreign policy magazine
today about this that there's a new sort
of revised isolationism that has come to
the fore in American politics Americans
have a tendency toward isolationism
we're very lucky geographically we're
surrounded on both sides by oceans and
to our south we have a weak state Mexico
and to our north a very friendly state
in Canada so the United States does not
have a lot of border problems in terms
of being in the middle of Europe for
example and facing down a threat from
multiple sides and so it that's men
typically is that Americans tend to have
this real isolationist streak which is
understandable the only problem is then
an era of mass communication in an era
of
easy jet travel an era of missiles and
and global trade it's very difficult to
isolate yourself from the world without
also harming yourself economically and
harming yourself in terms of security
and every time the United States has
tried to isolate itself and has said
okay let's turn inward let's cut our
military let's turn inward let's stop
worrying about what's happening over an
Estonia Latvia let's stop worrying
what's happening over in the South China
Sea every time we do that sort of thing
it ends up resounding not to our benefit
but to our detriment it always ends up
building to the point where rogue states
end up attacking us whether it's Japan
in World War two or whether it is
Germany in World War one we always end
up being dragged into wars against our
will because if you leave the the
playground and there's nobody there to
boss around you may not like bossing it
around the United States may not like
being the global organizer
but if we're not gonna organize you know
who's going to do it is Russia and China
and you may think that doesn't matter it
does matter when China starts cutting
off trade between all these southeastern
Asian countries and the United States
through sphere of influence it does
matter when they begin encroaching
territorially more and more toward
American interests it does matter
when trying to becomes more powerful and
Russia becomes more powerful in Eastern
Europe and starts threatening our
Western European allies and then all of
a sudden we get dragged into conflict
again except conflicts with an
emboldened and strengthened enemy like
Russia or a China okay they start under
Obama this isn't unique to trump but it
did start with Obama and it's continued
under Trump this sort of this sort of
prevention is in this idea that we're
going to just come back into our borders
and everything is going to be okay it
sounds like a beautiful idea every time
it's been tried it fails and this is
true not just with World War one in
World War two
Bill Clinton tried this in the 1990s by
slashing our military to the bone and
the result was 9/11 george w bush built
up the military and got aggressive on
the foreign policy sphere and we saw a
dramatic decrease in the number of
terrorist attacks on american soil then
he leaves office and the number of
terrorist attacks increases massively
because isis grows the fact is you
cannot remove yourself from the
international scene and hope that
everything is going to be okay and that
seems to be the premise of a lot of what
Trump is saying here and that's a
problem okay with all that said the
media are losing their ever loving minds
over Donald Trump and we're gonna have
to continue this over at daily wire but
I want to talk a little bit about the
fact the media keeps saying they keep
throwing around this term constitutional
crisis constitutional crisis I want to
talk about what
Sushil crisis actually looks like
whether it's a crisis or not and the
fact that the Constitution is actually
built to withstand crises it's built to
have crises and withstand them we'll
talk about all of that over at Daley
wire.com you're gonna have to go over
there to check it out plus my favorite
story of the day it's a fantastic story
you're not gonna want to miss it go to
Daley wire to check it out $8 a month
buys you access to daily wire you can
watch the rest of the show live you me
part of the mailbag which we're gonna do
in a couple of days here you know all
sorts of new goodies we're also giving
away free DVDs of my friend Jeremy
boring has a fantastic movie about the
border and about border security it's
called the Arroyo and you should go get
a subscription right now you get a free
copy of the Arroyo which is a terrific
terrific film about a small ranch or
living on the Arizona border whose Lynn
is being used as a thoroughfare for drug
cartels from Mexico and what he does
about it it's a really terrific film
you're gonna want to subscribe to The
Daily wires just to get that but then
you also get me live to get clayvin live
eight bucks a month plus if you if you
get that annual subscription then you
get a free DVD copy of the Arroyo so go
check that out right now we are the
largest conservative podcasts on the
interwebs
[Music]